[Music]
alcohol is not allowed into the
celebration in Times Square where
hundreds of thousands of revelers will
ring in the New Year but don't be
surprised if you see some folks sipping
champagne or another kind of adult
beverage on average Americans have about
four and a half drinks while celebrating
New Year's Eve damn you're looking how
many doubling that or thanks I see some
people haven't work so I'm taking a
little too far more than 16 percent of
women and 27 percent of men say they've
blacked out during their New Year's
celebration for anyone who's ever had
one of those nights you're boozy
behavior has inspired a new Museum in
Croatia Roxana Saberi gives us a tour to
a night the four of us will never forget
the nights we hope we'll never forget it
often turn into the mornings we don't
ever want to remember and whenever I see
a tooth Oh for anyone who's ever gotten
too tipsy been three sheets to the wind
how to drop too much and paid the price
the next day welcome to the world's
first Museum of hangovers which opened
this month in Zagreb Croatia co-founder
Reno du Bois Kovich says the idea was
born from a conversation among friends
about drinking at parties a friend spoke
about how he woke up with a bicycle
pedal in his pocket and I thought as I
listened to him why not set up a place a
museum with the collection of these
objects and stories that will illustrate
in a funny way these evenings of
drunkenness and the hangover the next
day the museum is laid out like a boozy
walk home with rooms resembling a street
storefronts a park and finally a bedroom
where you can piece your journey
together along the way our stories of
drunken escapades from around the world
guests begin their visit by wearing
goggles that simulate drunkenness
they're invited to throw a dart bull's
eye means no admission charge they can
also share their own store
by finishing the phrase I woke up with
entries that we can show you include no
money to stray dogs and a lot of
pumpkins but critics of the museum say
it doesn't take the dangers of drinking
seriously it's fine to drink in
moderation but that's not what this
museum is about psychiatrist dr. Gail
Saltz is concerned the museum glamorizes
over drinking it makes it look appealing
it makes it look like it's fun and
hilarious and for young people
especially that's gonna be a big draw
the founders hope to expand the museum
and include the downfall of drinking but
for now
visitors will only have their own
experiences to serve as a warning I'm
very impressed but also very horrified
because it brings back very bad memories
oh good memories are the same thing for
CBS this morning Saturday Roxana Saberi
London the only time the museum is not
open is on New Year's Day which seems
odd since it's the biggest I know we
joked I joked in the beginning there is
a serious side for all of this any type
of alcohol abuse or getting behind the
wheel after you've had something to
drink but there is also this interesting
side that obviously has been explored in
movies and now this museum where people
have a shared experience she's having
attention
you